test of a person's true value  death facing staring it down  johnny i got you  it's neurogenic shock he's dying  [Music]  you in there ah my head  so what now now  you find out what it  [Music]  you've is backed down from anything  in your life even when you maybe should  have  you go through night city knowing a  stray  bullet could end you while hailing a cab  but that's never stopped you from taking  action  you believe you cheated death it is  death that has cheated you  if you gotta kill kill  if you gotta burn it all to the ground  then let it burn yellow  of my house  would you rather live in pieces mr  nobody  or go down for all times in a place of  glory  don't never fade away  you